[Musique]
avec vous hélène frade bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour colline à la une de la
presse damien en parlait à l'instant les
inquiétudes sur la situation sanitaire
en corée du nord où le régime fait état
de près d'un million et demi de cas de
cas de fièvre pardon ressemble en tous
points aux coronavirus d'après le
journal sud coréen deux corées times qui
montre des soldats rassemblés devant le
ministère de la défense nord coréen à
pyongyang l'armée serait désormais
mobilisés pour distribuer des
médicaments l'ignorent lesquels à
travers toute la corée du nord de
cologna joongang daily annonce l'arrivée
hier en corée du nord toujours de trois
gros avion cargo en provenance de chine
selon le journal sud coréen les
appareils contenait des matériels du
matériel d'urgence pour faire face à ce
qui s'appelle s'apparente à une épidémie
de kobe de 19 le quotidien indique qu'il
s'agissait là des premiers vols entre la
corée du nord à la chine depuis le début
de la pandémie il ya deux ans et le
journal rapporte également que le
dirigeant de la corée du nord kim jong
eun qui a refusé jusque là les vaccins
du programme kovacs a publiquement
accusé des responsables de son propre
régime de ne pas avoir distribué à temps
l'aide médicale nécessaire
en chine la ville de shanghai a autorisé
la réouverture des commerces par étapes
après deux mois d'un confinement
extrêmement stricte la l'humanité
raconte comment cette stratégie zéro
qu'ovide de pékin provoque des tensions
dans le pays et pourrait finir par
bousculer le pouvoir à quelques mois du
20ème congrès du parti communiste
chinois le quotidien explique que la
légitimité du pcc pour être à terme se
trouver contrariée par l'arrêt de
nombreuses entreprises les difficultés
économiques des ménages ces difficultés
sont passés sous silence par la presse
officielle qui préfèrent dénoncer à
l'image du global times la façon dont le
néonazisme serait en train d'empoisonner
l'ukraine mais aussi l'europe avec la
complicité je cite des états unis à la
hindu on al ce matin une capture d'écran
d'une vidéo qui a été diffusée par le
ministère de la défense russe montrant
selon le quotidien chinois des membres
des services de renseignement ukrainiens
à évacuer en lusine asos talent de
marioupol escortés par des militaires
pro russe des soldats ukrainien d'azov
talent qui aurait été pour beaucoup
conduit en territoires pro-russes on en
parlait dans le journal le frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung importe que l'ukraine
espère pouvoir échanger ses combattants
contre des prisonniers russes mais selon
le quotidien allemand la propagande de
moscou pourrait être envisagé d'autres
plans y compris la tenue d'un grand
procès contre les supposés nazis
ukrainiens qui sont oms est accusée par
le kremlin d'avoir non pas défendu leur
ville contre les troupes russes mais
d'avoir bombardé leur propre ville et
tué leurs propres concitoyens les
combats se poursuivent en ukraine la
chasse aux oligarques russes aussi le
temps fait état de débats très vifs en
ce moment en suisse pour accélérer
l'exécution des sanctions contre la
russie d'après le quotidien la
confédération serait de plus en plus
mise sous pression par les états unis
pour bloquer les avoirs des affidés au
kremlin de ce dessin de chappatte
montrant un juge helvètes disant ne rien
voir de loge dans le chalet d'un
propriétaire russe appelée baptisé mon
petit magot la suisse doit fermer les
yeux plaide le journal en égratignant au
passage paul et l'hypocrisie des états
unis où le delaware de joe biden est
champion en matière d'opa cité à la une
également cette étude élèves qui
accusent la pollution d'être responsable
de 9 millions de morts chaque année à
travers la planète et relayée notamment
par le monde cette étude de la revue
scientifique britannique de 27 affirment
que les polluants de l'air de l'eau et
des sols cause trois fois plus de morts
que le sida la tuberculose et le
paludisme
les pays dits en développement étant
particulièrement concernés à des
milliers de kilomètres de là en france
la question de l'environnement et de la
transition écologique ont été définis on
le sait par emmanuel macron comme l'une
des priorités du nhs gouvernement
d'elisabeth bornes interpellé ce matin
par libération qui l'accusent d'être une
écolo mollo le décor le voit est certes
champêtre l'allusion amoureuse mais la
requête sans ambiguïté changement
climatique ça urge un peu beaucoup à la
folie peut-être on ne s'équipent pas là
dessus le parisien pauline fait état
d'une bonne nouvelle la victoire hier de
l'erythrée à binyam jrm est entré dans
l'histoire du cyclisme en devenant le
premier noir africain à remporter une
étape d'un grand tour en s'imposant sur
le giro italien
la moins bonne nouvelle c'est que le
cycliste a dû être hospitalisé après
s'être blessé en débouchant la
traditionnelle bouteille de mousse sur
le podium comme le montre cette photo où
on le voit pencher sur la bouteille se
tenir le côté gauche du visage au moment
où le bouchon saute un point est prévu
ce matin pour savoir si le cycliste
pourra reprendre la course mais il ya
quelques jours un autre cycliste avait
failli subir le même incident au moment
d'endosser le maillot rose le petit
rappel de la sécurité routière s'impose
voire aux pédales et il faut
merci beaucoup lna